so people can't get traditional funding
for their tiny homes and how a most
people paying for them are they
hopefully they're not using credit cards
but maybe oh well just just say these
over the years yeah I think a lot of
people sort of say about you know and
buy it in cash or you know I think we
went to visit a couple up in Sonoma
Valley and they were sort of you know
they finished the structure of the tiny
house and had it had you know plywood
walls and everything in but they were
sort of living in it as they were
finishing it you know things like the
finished flooring and you know the the
finish work in the details that's not
necessarily necessary to live in it so
they were kind of finishing it little by
little over time as they were getting
money from working I mean you you know
funded the house sort of by working as
you went along and yeah most of my most
the house that we build with yeah i've
funded out of pocket you know i think
another big sources loans from family
which is nice because you know they have
a sort of the best that interested in
you in your patient house and having
place to live so i had a lot of support
from my family and they've been real
generous with that part of the reason
that i went that route was actually just
because the project that you know having
making this film about it we couldn't
draw it out for two or three years but I
could have easily just you know built in
as I as I worked and just taking a
little longer and funded it all out of
pocket but you know because we were kind
of needed to go at a quicker rate you
know I had to sort of take some loans
that I might not have otherwise done but
you know that's that's the more of the
nature of being an independent filmmaker
then you know the reflection of tiny
houses and their financial there are I
mean people out there who have done them
you know for less than $10,000 or even I
think it's sort of a trade-off for you
know time versus money so if you're not
if you don't necessarily need to finish
the house in a specific timeframe you
have more time to find materials on
Craigslist or you know to find used
building materials or you know to save
money in
but you know more more creative because
you have the time to kind of wait and
look for things to turn up it's that my
truth and it's all solar-powered is that
how it's okay yeah there's one thing
that we that's really great about this
particular project it's probably isn't
work for most documentaries but because
there's this tie-in with home
improvement and building there are a
number of businesses and corporations
out there who are willing to support the
project cuz it in you know doesn't
encourage people to you know to take on
similar projects themselves and so one
of our partners is a off the grid solar
company called solutions yeah and then
they have a product called the soul man
and it's a basically a little cart that
the panels are built on to an everyday
self-contained
power like solar generator that you
basically just run an extension or to
the house and so I was able to wire the
tiny house all normal 120 volt AC yeah
and and you know there it goes through a
breaker and that breaker it just goes
out to a plug and so we just plug in the
solar generator into the house and what
benefit of that is we can either run it
off the solar generator or if we were
ever in the backyard and needed to tie
it to the grid it's as simple as just
plugging it into the wall yeah so the
electricity has also learned then the
heat is actually a small heater made for
sailboats that's a propane heater and
then our cooking stove is an alcohol
burning sailboat stove so actually a lot
of the utilities used in tiny houses are
made for sailboats or our views because
they're kind of made for small spaces
yeah that one thing just another plug
for one of our sponsors which is
Dickinson marine and they were the ones
who we got the to sell a heater from and
a lots of tiny houses of pretty much I'd
say 80% of tiny houses have one of these
heaters in them and they're really
awesome for small spaces and tiny house
lemmings though but again it's I just
want to throw that in there because you
know it's because these companies have
been so important that we were so able
to do this
you